Okay.
I want to mention again,
campaign monitor.
Campaign monitor is a,
a tool I'm told that,
uh,
helps you send great looking emails to a large audience and it has templates and
drag and drop editors and full support seven days a week.
I'm having a lot of trouble understanding exactly what campaign monitors all
about and so I'm going to reach out to the company next week,
uh,
and really get into it so that I can better promote their product.
In the meantime,
please visit campaign monitor.com/conan today.
Try It for free.
No cards,
no contracts.
That's campaign monitor.com/conan campaign monitor.
Make your emails unforgettable.
Hey,
Sonia.
In other way,
I'm always saying,
ah,
I got to go to the gym.
I'm going to jump on the treadmill.
I want to bring my iPhone,
but oh man,
do I have to bring the whole iPhone?
I say that.
Okay,
good.
Plan along will anyway.
Uh,
there's a great device.
If that's your problem,
it's called Palm.
It's back and it's available on Verizon.
It's this small companion device.
It syncs with your existing smartphone and it seamlessly connected.
You get to do all this stuff you can with your smart phone,
but it's much smaller.
That's nice.
Yeah.
You pressed the Internet.
Okay.
That's just because I put my phone down sideways.
See,
I shouldn't have an iPhone.
It's ridiculous.
I should need something smaller.
What could I get that smaller that seamlessly connects to my iPhone?
I mean off the top of my head may be a Paul.
I should get a palm.
Palm is great.
Not a replacement for your smartphone,
but a great ancillary device.
I hope I use that word correctly.
Go to palm.com to learn more.
Run to your nearest Verizon store.
Don't really run.
Just get there quickly and safely and checkout pawn for yourself.
Hi.
My name is Ron Funches
and I feel grateful and excited about being Conan O'Brien's brand.
I've always wanted to be
phones.
Hey there.
Welcome to Conan O'brien needs a friend.
This is the show where I use basically a podcast to meet people,
see if there'll be my friend or talk to friends and wonder why we're not better
friends.
It's a scam,
really.
The one that seems to be working.
I'm here with my trusty assistant,
Sonoma of Sassy and hey,
sona.
Hi.
You think I'm a pretty cool guy,
right?
And my producer Matt Gorley.
Hi.
Thank you,
Matt.
You,
uh,
you are the glue that holds this thing together.
I'm trying.
Yeah,
you really are.
You are the gums.
You're the fleshy red gums that hold the teeth in alignment.
You're covered in saliva and you're prone to disease.
Anyway,
today's guest is a hilarious comedian
and also a terrific,
terrific human being.
I just toured with him.
His name is Ron Funches,
my podcast just at my house.
And my mom brings you coffee.
Will you do it?
I will do it.
You know,
I want to point out to people that I've been touring with you and I just spent,
I don't know,
almost a week with you and got to know you really well.
I've always known you always loved your comedy.
I love you as a comic and I love Your Voice,
both your actual voice and your view of the world.
You do this thing as a comedian.
That is so rare,
you almost start your act by saying,
I like to talk about things that make me happy.
I like to talk about positive things.
And so many comics come out and they have an ax to grind or they're talking
about what's wrong with the world and you just talk about things that make you
happy and it's,
and it's hilarious.
It's really funny,
but it's a completely unique approach.
Um,
and it's just what I like to do,
especially when I realized the job was saying the same jokes over and over and
over again.
Um,
I was like,
I don't want to go out there and be angry every night and,
and manufacturer and some anger or,
um,
and I don't,
that doesn't mean I like to try to shy away from negative aspects of my life is
just in general,
my,
my viewpoint and the perspective I have,
I try to keep as what is the positive of the situation.
I tried to write my jokes about that.
And one of my favorite jokes when I was first starting out was just this joke I
wrote about the time where I was crossing the street from my apartment to a
convenience store and I was stuck in the middle of this intersection and this
guy just yelled at me and was like,
use the crossword cross walk inward.
And I would use the crosswork crosswalk and word wow.
And um,
and so to me,
I,
you know,
just like you're like,
oh,
there's nothing negative,
nothing positive about that.
But I took a joke about that and I was like,
oh,
he's just worried about my safety
would really prove her and he doesn't want to hit me.
He's
racist.
But uh,
he is concerned for your safety.
Yes.
So,
okay.
So there's some pieces that up there.
He's a safety conscious racist.
I see.
You really did find the silver lining.
Uh,
you know,
it's,
it's funny too because you come out as it as a,
when you hit the stage as a comic,
it's so interesting because the things you're talking about are things that you
wouldn't guess it all from looking at you.
Like you say,
I love rat professional wrestling.
I didn't know that.
It's not something that I would have assumed that you loved,
that you love professional wrestling and you delight in professional wrestling.
I think you really believe it's the greatest form of entertainment in the
history of the world.
Yes.
Is the best.
And um,
it's the most open as far as like,
look,
we're fake.
You know,
we're not real.
We're fake fight.
And um,
it was,
it overall we're all just working together to entertain people.
We're not trying to hurt each other.
To me that makes way more sense than something like UFC or boxing where you're
like real legitimate,
really trying to hurt each other.
Right.
And then that's why these people end up doing five or six fights and then they
have to retire.
And it's just like,
why don't you just do 30 years of fake fights?
And you make more money.
It makes sense to me.
Yeah.
More entertaining to me.
I don't want you getting hurt.
It's not entertaining to me.
Right.
It's like the show is entertaining to me.
You know,
so that's how I look at it.
You,
uh,
you also,
you ate ally's Dwayne the Rock Johnson.
Yeah.
But I mean a lot of people do,
but you have,
he's like a God like figure to you.
Yeah.
Just because he did so many great things in wrestling.
He's the best wrestler ever because he became extremely popular at wrestling and
then he left and didn't movies and then was great at that and then never had to
come back.
He's still wrestles when he wants to,
but he doesn't have to go back.
He doesn't need the money.
And he took his,
a lot of wrestlers,
you know,
they,
they get hot and you get a little bit of fame,
but they don't know how to handle their money and they never transitioned into
something else.
And he was one of the first people that was like,
I'm going to take these same skills that makes me great.
And wrestling and I'm gonna apply those to acting and I'm going to do roles that
people don't expect me to do.
I'm not just going to do action movies.
I'm going to do all types of movies.
And,
and he was the tooth fairy.
He was a to fairy.
But he do,
I mean he did a lot of the things he was in.
Um,
I think gets shorty,
he had a really small cameo role but was really good.
We played a really against type and um,
I was just,
that's when I was like,
oh,
he is taking the series came in the fast and furious movies.
I do,
why I learn to like them now because my son loves them so much.
This is the secret to those movies,
especially as they progress once you get to four or five,
six,
seven,
I think they're on 55 now one.
But the thing I learned about those movies is watched them as comedies and,
and uh,
Larry,
they are absolutely fucking laugh out loud.
Hilarious.
And there's a scene in particular that I was watching it.
I think maybe I was talking to you about this.
There's a scene in,
I think it's maybe too fast and furious movies ago before they battled a
submarine with cars,
but there was a scene where the rock and vin diesel,
and this might be the beginning of where you can tell they don't like each
other,
but the rock and vin diesel have to be saying goodbye to each other at the end
of the movie.
And they're a chin to chin almost staring at each other.
But each looking past each other while they're having a conversation and you
need to go and look at that.
I think it might be,
it is one of the most amazing,
they made a choice and I think it was they neither character.
Each character thought they were too cool to look at the other character.
So they're looking past each other,
but their faces are almost touching and I've never seen two humans interact like
that before.
It's beautiful.
I just want her not to,
you know,
crazy.
Just the behind the scenes on that type of thing.
There's so many egos on the fast and the furious that I imagine,
I love to see it.
I'd love to see it.
I'm going to say something and you don't think I'm crazy.
I shot something with
uh,
the rock.
I shot a remote with him.
I want to say about,
uh,
nine months ago.
It was during a period when I was working out hard and the rock showed up and I
swear to
God I think I could take them in a fight.
I was looking at him and I was thinking I'm going to go for it.
I think I could take him.
I think first of all I would have surprise.
Yeah you would definitely has surprise.
No one would see that come and no one would see that coming.
And I would,
I would go,
I would go in hard and quick like that's just,
and I would try and do too.
We'll take the leg.
Uh No,
no,
no.
I would go first of all I'd go for his face cause I know that he would be self
con cause he's a movie star.
Yeah.
To be a little panic
and worried about his face.
So I'd go for the face and then I would just,
I would rip through his chest.
I would just go through him like a wild animal.
I mean you have that type of look.
I feel like there's a part of you that has it raged at your height and,
and are not hiding.
You know,
I am a very angry guy.
I am a very,
you know,
people that know me know I'm an angry guy and then I'm trying to be nice.
I really am.
It's just,
I'm trying to have good pencils at all.
I don't think that's true at all from the time that we spent together this last
week is one the reasons why I feel,
um,
closer to you is that I was like,
Oh I think you have to be nice.
I think sometimes you don't want to be as nice as you are,
but you,
you,
there's something in you that makes you be nice.
And,
and I had that in me as well.
Um,
but I just see the way that you interact with fans after the show and when
you're interacting with comedians after the show and there's just,
or the fact that we were laying on the flight and then you brought me a pillow
or you moved a little,
no you didn't.
Brandy brought my pillow,
but you move the little snacks that were blocking my feet so that I can rest a
little bit.
And this is just a nice guy.
Oh,
I am,
I am a nice person.
I'm being a hundred percent honest right now.
I am a nice,
uh,
and I,
I credit a lot of that to my mom and also probably somewhat to Catholicism,
but,
uh,
she drilled,
you know,
she drilled into us,
be nice and I want to make people happy,
but sometimes,
uh,
if I think people are taking advantage of a situation,
um,
or if someone really screws me over or screws over someone I care about,
I am capable of immense hatred and the hatred that lasts a lifetime as two sides
of a coin though,
right?
It's like if you're,
if you're able to be so nice and be so giving,
there's always going to be that other side of you.
I have that with me where,
um,
cause people are always like,
you're so chill and you're so relaxed and you're nice to everybody.
But I was like,
yeah,
but if you cross a certain line to me it's just,
I don't care.
I'm not like,
Oh,
I wish for your destruction.
I think it's just the fence.
I was like,
Oh,
you're dead to me.
You mean nothing to me.
And I,
if I cut you out,
I cut you out.
And,
um,
it's not,
I don't know if that's,
I think it's a good skill is you as it's been used useful in the past,
but um,
sometimes they have to learn now I think especially with relationships,
I learned to not be looking for reasons to cut people out.
We were out there on the,
are you in the dating world right now?
You have a steady girlfriend,
girlfriend.
She's going to be coming to Wa.
That's on the second part of this trip.
She's excited.
So I'll get to know her a little bit.
Yeah.
She loves you a lot.
Should I a question her about a lot of things.
Find out about her,
if anything,
a tempter to be like,
Hey,
leave Ron and come be with me and my [inaudible]
you want me to do that?
To test her
test her resolve.
You know,
the problem is I'm not the sexiest guy to dangle in front of me.
Doesn't care much for that.
I found out I'm the sex.
Why did you say,
wait?
Why did you just agree with what I put out?
Yeah.
No,
I do agree.
Yeah.
You had such an opportunity,
you had an opportunity to go like Conan.
No,
but you just,
you,
you said no,
no,
no.
She doesn't care about that will be fun.
Are a non just muscle similar to myself.
You are a nontraditional good looking man.
As in like if you were to ask people what were the features that most people
want and a man you,
I really have.
No,
that's great.
I could not agree with you more
fudge mixed together when people were just the kind of like,
it's like a Picasso where you're like,
it's,
it looks,
it's what is supposed to look.
So you're thinking,
God,
what's just say that there was a god,
you know,
the,
it created me and he just said like,
Eh,
it's supposed to look like that.
And then he moved on to like Ryan Gosling.
Right?
More like he was like,
uh,
I want to be able to keep an eye on this one,
so I'm going to make sure I could see them from far.
Okay.
You're very honest.
That's the other thing I noticed about,
oh,
because of the car,
the guitar thing.
Oh God,
that killed me.
Uh,
we were,
uh,
I'll just tell people that are listening to us on tour.
Just last week with Ron and one
of the other comics,
uh,
James Beach,
he got a new guitar and he was very excited about it and acoustic guitar and he
was backstage and I have an acoustic guitar.
I always have a guitar around just cause it calms me down.
So we tuned up together just to test out his guitar and we just both started
playing something.
We were wandering.
The next thing I know we were,
I think we were in a dressing room and you were in there and you were suddenly
confronted by these two incredibly Pale white guys with acoustic guitars,
singing,
focusing music,
not my first time.
Okay.
I immediately,
to my credit,
saw the look on your face and knew,
oh,
we gotta get the fuck out of here.
So I left,
I think James stuck around a little bit,
but you then proceeded to go out on stage and talk about it to the audience.
And it was hilarious.
I thought it was really funny.
Yeah,
it was really fun.
I mean it just,
and it was a fun experience because it was just me and Taylor Tomlinson.
I'm backstage before you got back there and James let's just there with his new
guitar and he was tuning it up and he was asking requests and Taylor was trying
to be sweet and so she was just like,
oh,
I can't think of she,
she also was not having fun and so she was just trying to be sweet and she was
like,
I can't think of anything.
And he was like,
Ryan,
you got any request?
I just go,
ah,
you're good at this.
But to be honest,
this just makes me uncomfortable.
Yeah,
I would do.
Um,
I remember when our head writer Mike Sweeney,
who,
you know,
uh,
Mike's Mike Sweetie years and go on the late night show,
it was his first day at work and he was about to leave for the day and I stepped
up to him with an acoustic guitar and started singing in his face and he said he
didn't know me well enough to know that I was doing it in a joking way to be
annoying.
He was horrified
because there is nothing you can do in that situation when you're confronted by
people playing their instrument,
even if they're really good,
you're,
and if you're a comedian,
you can't sit there and go like,
yeah man,
that's really good.
Yeah,
it's placed you in a bad position because you,
especially if you don't know the person,
you can just tune everything out.
But if you know them at all,
it's becomes like they're your three year old and you have to sit there and be
like,
yeah,
yeah.
Well you said a really funny thing on stage I,
Comfortable writing it.
I'm always comfortable tell people what you said.
You went on stage and you described,
oh,
said that you force us to listen to you play guitar in the dressing room 30
minutes before the show.
And that I don't fully understand,
but now I get the gist of the women who had the deal with Louis C K women
the corner and be like,
yeah,
audience really thought that was funny.
I laughed and went back to the agent Brooke,
my guitar and half,
you know,
who really liked it,
was there all the staff on the plane
and they're like,
good.
Finally,
uh,
let's talk about you.
Very inspiring part of your life is that how long ago?
About a year and a half ago.
Two years ago.
You just,
you lost,
you decided I'm going to,
I'm going to lose weight.
So coming up,
I be almost three years now.
Almost three years now.
Um,
it was around Thanksgiving three years ago.
Yeah.
When I was at my heaviest,
I was at like three,
360 pounds and,
and you know,
I always been a heavy person and floating around 300.
Um,
and then when I got a on undateable and got some money,
I was,
had a lot more options.
And so I was able to be used to be like,
all right,
cheesecake for lunch and cheese steak for dinner and just ballooned up and put
it on another 50 pounds and was up to three 16.
And that's when we talked on the plane about how my mom was just,
she came to visit me and she was like,
I don't like buying new clothes this big.
And then Bill Lawrence on the show was like,
Hey,
I noticed you in the gym the first season and then you come back second season
and then look like it stuck.
Uh,
so if you,
if you're want to,
if you want more tools about this and you need help,
um,
oh it hook you up with my trainer.
And then bill paid for the trainer for the first year and,
and,
and just supported me and it was really,
he's a nice guy.
He's a very nice guy.
I really liked it because,
you know,
the character on the show was when,
when I got the role with like he's the overweight like shy guy and they,
and he was just like,
look,
you're finding like we don't,
we don't need you to be this guy.
You can,
you just be yourself and be healthy and that will be fine.
And so you lost all this weight and you said,
you said you're still,
um,
I should probably point out to people you're drinking a glass of gravy.
Never saw he didn't know if it came in cans.
Yeah.
It was a step above eggnog.
No,
cause I,
you know,
I,
it's funny because you said that you're still getting used to your new body.
Oh yeah.
You told me it's set up straight.
Yeah.
I,
I'm very,
uh,
I'm always giving my son telling him like,
come on your posture and I,
I saw you like slumped over at one point and I,
and I just was kidding around and I was like,
come on and sit up straight you.
And you said,
well,
I'm getting used to my new body.
And I thought,
Oh shit,
no,
I just,
cause I again,
I was like,
Oh yeah,
thank you.
Because this is just the true for like,
I mean it was one of the reasons why I started going to wrestling school for a
little bit when,
so that I could throw my body around and figuring out where it ends and begins.
And,
um,
even now,
like when I go to workout and I'm doing set ups and my trainer goes to pick me
up,
I like reach back and like,
you know,
try to brace myself as if I'm heavier.
Like I can't get up.
And he's like,
and he'll stop me.
He'll go like,
just get up.
You can get up.
You're,
you're not that heavy.
Just get up.
And I have to remember that.
And you've,
uh,
you've found it to be advantageous and your sex life.
Yeah.
I can pick people up.
I can go longer and as fun.
Um,
and I mean,
but what's great people up?
Don't pick people at,
Oh,
I mean,
what are you talking about?
You've got to have stronger arm.
No,
it's not because I can't,
I wouldn't know what to do.
What does that mean?
Pick them up,
pick,
come up and carry him and place them on yourself?
Oh yeah.
I would.
I was never occurred to me to do that.
Well,
I mean,
I was feeling adventurous for sure.
It didn't last long and then put her down,
but she was very excited about the time.
She likes to cheat.
You could pick it up and you said that if you're having sex standing up.
Yeah.
That's a big thing too.
That's my main,
picked her up.
Oh,
you picked her up and then you're acting out.
Okay.
I'm not even sure me of the status.
Can you pick me up and show me exactly.
I would need for that to happen.
I would need a series of pulleys and
I was feeling brave and I happened.
Wow.
That's like you were in the moment of just raw passion and power.
You know,
such a powerful tool you have is your voice.
Your Voice is so disarming.
You're so likable.
You are one of the most likable performers that I've encountered,
which is why I was so happy when you agreed to go on the tour with me.
Did you always like your voice to people?
Oh no,
of course not.
Especially being a,
you know,
a black kid from Chicago.
It w w having a sweet little voice wasn't the,
you know,
wasn't ideal.
It would,
it made you a target if anything.
And um,
a lot of people made fun of me for it.
But that's,
I mean that's one of the lessons I learned quickly was things that people make
fun of you for and are usually the things that set you apart and the things that
you can then use to your advantage later.
He told me this once,
you used to use your voice a lot,
you had a job working for a bank and people would only know you through the
phone,
isn't that right?
Yeah.
And,
and,
and you said that your voice deceived people sometimes.
Sometimes they thought I was a southern lady and I would just play it out.
You would not disabuse them of that notion.
You would let them believe that you were a southern lady.
Cause you know,
I be like,
hi,
I'm Ron.
But eventually they just hear Rhonda and Mel.
Thank you Rhonda.
You're so saw.
I'm like,
oh no worries.
Yeah,
you were also very,
you talked about this on my show,
but you were
very,
uh,
you real human being.
You wanted to be a human being on the other end of the phone when you
represented a bank,
you didn't want to just be a robot who couldn't help people to be a human being.
Yeah,
I like to give money back.
Um,
I just never really liked banks that much.
They seem very predatory from the outside in.
And then when I was working at this bank I was like,
okay,
definitely predatory.
But just from the way they structure the fees and available balance compared to
your actual balance and it's just,
it came,
became hard to like listen to people on the phone and just be like,
and they were explaining to you,
it's like,
look,
I overdrew by a dollar and you guys charge me like $150 in fees and I'm singing
the math and I'm seeing they're correct and I'm supposed to just,
you know,
lie to them and be like,
well,
you did this.
You didn't,
you didn't know about this.
And I'd been,
should I just went,
Nah,
I'm just giving him,
it's not my money.
I'm just gonna give it back until they fire me.
So you kept giving back money when you weren't supposed to and um,
making the customer on the phone happy.
What point did the bank find out what you were doing?
Um,
about like six months.
They usually have like little,
um,
they go over your scores and things.
And so what they would find is that I have like the highest survey call scores
because people like that I give them money back and that I was a southern lady
and then I'd also have the highest amount of money given back.
So they would try to,
you know,
they're just try to teach me not to do it.
And I'd be like,
yeah,
I'll work at it.
And I just get more.
I mean,
mostly I just stopped showing up to work because I was,
that's when I started doing standup was working at that bank.
They,
because I was so good at the coal part of it,
they,
um,
let me make like a little funny video about helping other people deal with
stress at the job.
And they took me off the phone for a couple of weeks and I made this fun video
that was just really corporatey but with dumb little corporate jokes.
And then they showed it at the corporate retreat.
And so I got to here like 400 people just laughing at these dumb jokes and,
and then in my hand and he was like,
oh,
they're laughing at things I don't think are funny.
What if I did things that I thought were funny.
And so it,
from then on I was like,
okay,
I'm a,
I want to do comedy.
And then they were like,
go back on the phones and I was like,
no.
So I just go,
yeah.
So,
but I had my son and so I just,
I just stopped showing up and kept getting paychecks for a few weeks until that,
until they fire me.
It was pretty sweet.
Yeah.
So the comedy worked out pretty quickly.
It worked out quicker than most.
I have to always remember that,
especially around my friends.
Um,
I'd say about six,
six years was when I probably started getting some money and cause I was like
right around when I got on your show and,
but before then there was,
I mean there was five years of me raising my son and um,
he has autism and so we had a lot of like his like social security
money and then I was working on a part time job as a little lady liberty dancer,
but like dirt,
no real money.
We were living like,
you know,
under and definitely like under 1500 a month,
for a few years.
And so that was,
I mean that's why I spoil him now.
Here's the Fun Dad.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He is any video game he wants.
He has four multiple systems he is seeing and you bake,
you bake cookies for him.
Yeah,
I blood cooking for my girlfriends.
Started baking cookies for him.
She,
she's trying to earn his trust.
That's sweet.
Yeah.
That's really nice.
And that's also a good test for you.
You wanted me to test this girlfriend,
but if she's making cookies for your son.
Yeah.
She's already passed that test.
Yeah,
no,
I trust her.
I will try to sleep with her place.
She'll get a thrill out of,
I will say,
listen,
I may be an unconventional assembly of odd features.
I may be a Picasso ask mass,
but I am going to bed you
and there's little that you can't escape the charm of these thin lips.
Okay.
BDIS translucent skin.
Good though.
Actually.
I mean I see this when you on this suit it up your fun,
but casual Kona is a pretty hot and I see what I can see it.
I can see people once they carry and that guitar around.
Oh
now it's time for a segment.
Conan O'brien pays off the mortgage on his beach house.
Pay Them bills,
dollar bill dollar bill,
Mike,
Bill Dolla bill.
That's how it was.
I'm just talking the way that kids talk these days and you think I don't get out
much.
I've been excited about many of the products we've discussed here on the show,
but I honestly have to say butcher box.
That's a company that I understand.
You know why they send you meet.
We've talked about some esoteric websites here,
have we not?
And it gets a little confusing sometimes and then sometimes you might think this
Conan,
really nobody's talking about,
guess what?
I'm on solid ground right now cause butcher box delivers grass fed grass
finished beef,
organic chicken,
pork,
wild Alaskan Salmon.
This is good stuff.
Any company that sends me great protein through the mail,
Bang,
I'm there.
I get it.
I understand it.
It's exciting.
It is exciting.
It's a lot of fun.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know why I'm like this.
Today is a lot of fun.
I'm sorry.
I don't,
you're going to get sued by Aubrey Plaza.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Stealing her whole bit.
I'm such an excited person.
But listen,
you love,
you love yourself.
You're dead.
To which is the Greek term for,
for grandfather.
Is it Greek?
What's Shit?
That's Armenio.
I don't,
I think so.
Anyway.
You're always say,
oh my dad,
my dad,
dad was a butcher.
My debt was a butcher,
my dead,
it was a butcher.
That's all she says.
You're your Delta devoted his whole life to meet.
And how there's butcher box.
They would have loved this.
Yeah.
You can choose from a variety of curated boxes or you can customize your own
box.
Amit.
That's incredible.
Each box comes with at least nine to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for,
it says here,
24 individual size meals.
Not In my family,
man.
Where did they,
yes.
And that to the O'bryan house in Brookline,
mass.
Here's nine to 11 pounds of meat.
That should take care of 24 people and Nope,
it took care of one.
It's ridiculous.
We Chow down in my family anyway,
it's all just $129 a month that works out to less than $6 a meal.
You know,
me,
Sona,
I likes me,
my protein.
Uh,
yeah.
I wonder why we're both Popeye in this scenario.
I got,
got,
got.
I likes me mean protein,
but I do,
I really do love,
uh,
this,
this whole concept and the website,
uh,
breaks it all down for you.
So you know,
all the different qualities of meat educates you.
It's pretty cool.
New Subscribers get $20 off your first box and two pounds of free salmon.
When you go to butcher box.com/conan that's butcher box.com/conan for $20 off
your first box and two pounds of free salmon.
You know what,
where my mind goes right now I picture a bear getting on a website.
It's paused working to keys and ordering some salmon rather than going to the
waterfall and having to catch one weird and is it jumps up,
you know what I mean?
Can you just see a bear trying to catch salmon jumping up the river and it's
having a hard time.
If I directed an ad for butcher box and we'd be a bear frustrated missing the
salmon,
then shrugging and you see the bear walking to its cave and then it gets on the
computer and it goes on butcher box and it ordered salmon and salmon is probably
would not be a fun and I like that Ad.
Well I missed my calling.
I could have been a mid level advertising EXEC,
but no,
I chose fame.
Sad.
Anyway,
that's it.
Butcher box.
You know what to do.
Estonia,
as you're aware,
I'm not very good with money.
You're not terrible.
Well what,
what do you mean really at it?
I was just saying I'm not that great.
Why are you going that far?
But we have a whole segment dedicated to you paying off your beach house cause
you made a lot of bad financial decisions.
So I guess that's true point.
Yeah.
I,
I'm often confused by finance.
I've made some pretty bad investments.
I've invested in a lot of theme restaurants that had really bad themes.
Like what there was that a French fry restaurant that was based on the potato
famine and uh,
that
we put 17 of those in the valley and they all went belly up pretty quickly.
I apologize for that.
So I need help.
I need help investing.
And that's where Robin Hood comes in.
No,
I'm not talking about that.
Legendary Archer in the woods.
That laugh was too long.
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets you buy and sell stocks,
ETFs,
options,
cryptos and guess what?
It's all commission free.
And guess what?
I don't know what ETFs in Cryptos are,
but the point is,
if you're like me,
a stock market newcomer,
uh,
this is a,
an app that really explains things for you.
It makes it pretty easy.
You know,
other brokerages charge up to $10 for every trade.
Can you imagine that?
Yes.
Really Nice.
Too Much
God.
It's the worst performance.
It is too much.
I'm not going to pay this pay $10 every time I make a trade.
That's ridiculous.
Robin Hood doesn't charge commissions.
Absolutely incredible.
And they have this really easy to understand chart.
They have market data that even I can understand.
Can you imagine that?
That's amazing.
Yeah.
And you can trade on your smartphone and just four taps.
I that might not be good for me.
I would make bad decisions because if my,
if I could just do it on my phone,
I'm going to be much more likely to,
uh,
you know,
invest in a company that makes you know,
helmets for orangutans or something.
So,
um,
but anyway,
most people,
we don't want them getting apes grape,
ape scrape.
Yeah.
That's all right,
Matt.
You've heard of apes,
apes grape.
Keep your ape safe with apes,
grape,
ape swinging the jungle all the time.
But they do suffer a head injuries,
orangutans,
chimpanzees,
so get them a helmet with apes.
Great.
We just made that up.
But if someone wants to make that company a,
I'll do the ad for it for free anyway.
Robin Hood is giving listeners a free stock like Apple Ford or sprint sign up at
Conan dot.
Robin hood.com.
That's Conan doc Robin,
hood.com.
And if you're interested in a helmet for your eight Matt Gorley and I was
turning a new company called Ayp scrape,
you are,
uh,
someone who
likes to enjoy life.
And for you that does mean video games.
You love video games.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
You love marijuana.
I do.
I may be the last person alive that calls it marijuana.
I try to balance it out though.
I don't like to feel,
um,
a compromise as my trainer will say anytime I'm not doing well on my exercises.
Um,
and just try,
keep a balance
but half fun.
And once I realize again that my job is to have fun and make people have fun.
Then I was like,
Oh hey,
good to do this.
I get to just smoke pot and play video games because I'm supposed to be having
fun.
I'm supposed to be adjuster and why would I go around acting serious or try to
be in?
I think as a trap of when you get a little bit of success is then you're like,
oh,
now I need to buckle down and be real professional because that's what they want
and it's just like,
no,
they would you want it is what you were in the very beginning.
I've had people tell them
that it would be good for me to smoke pot or
because I'm seeing tightly wound to them and I've had a number of people over
the years say it would be good if you took edibles or smoked pot if you did some
of that.
Is that something since we are now friends and the fact that you're on this
podcast means that we are friends.
Yeah.
You know this is you've,
you've made it.
This is a huge deal.
I like for you.
What do you think?
Be honest with me.
Do you,
do you think I need to be a little medicated?
Wait,
no.
Um,
I'm not always,
I'm never a guy who like pushes people into smoking a bunch of pot if they don't
want to.
It seems like you're too old to start.
Uh,
36 years old,
although my mom has recently started it and she is loving it.
Um,
so it can be helpful.
But you know,
how old is your mom?
My mom is 62.
Okay.
So I'm a,
I'm good deal younger than your mom.
Yeah.
Okay.
But I don't want you to put me in the mom category.
Yeah,
that's true.
So you think I'm to a match,
going to count it up.
Your personality,
I think to change that and mellow you out,
it would be to Dole.
What,
um,
what makes you you.
And if you want to do it just for fun,
I would love to smoke pot with you.
That would be a dream come true.
But,
and also so Phonto videotape.
Uh,
but can you do it?
Should we do it on the next leg of the tour?
Yeah,
for sure.
Did we smoke it or do we eat something?
How does it work?
I don't even know how I'm going to do both.
But whatever you decide for yourself.
I don't think starting with edibles is a good idea.
Too Strong,
too strong and you don't know what you're doing and getting into,
I had rather I would rather set up a fun evening for you where it's like,
okay,
we'll get your guitar out and we'll get,
I dunno know
guitar is not part of this equation.
We're not,
I'm never,
you are never going to see me with a guitar.
Yeah.
After you compare it need to,
do you know what you did?
I am never doing that again,
man.
Moses,
that is not how I mastered it.
Mine is more like playing a cello.
I masturbate.
But um,
why do you want to,
do you want to?
I don't know.
I've mixed.
I,
I usually don't want to,
I usually don't watch because I,
she'll like,
uh,
I overall like who I am and if I want to take the edge off,
to me that's two glasses of wine.
That's my kind of thing.
Whereas opposed to,
I don't know what you call him,
jazz cigarettes,
Wacky Tobacky,
you know,
uh,
I don't know what your kids call it these days.
Devil's lettuce.
I don't know.
I think,
uh,
I don't think that's a good fit for me.
You know?
And I think you got to know who you are.
I can't drink.
I'm allergic to alcohol.
It makes me projectile vomit and my throat close up.
Is that true?
Yeah.
So I can,
so for me it was just like,
that's not what you find that out.
18.
Oh my God.
You took one drink and your throat closed up and you did,
you almost die.
I laid down at a party and I just waited for it to pass.
And then my friends were like,
maybe it was what you drank,
so let's try something different.
And then it happened again.
And so I was like,
okay,
let's just do this,
just isn't for me.
And then they said,
nope,
we've got to go through every type of [inaudible].
They were like,
yes,
because that's how your friends that aren't,
we're not done with you yet.
But I was like,
and for me,
I'd always had an interest in pot and I'm like,
I talked to my son about it and he has no interest in it.
You know,
he's,
he has more interest in beer.
Just something he always liked it.
We go to baseball games and he just always here the guy and he just yelled at
Alli ice cold beer.
And so now as he's older,
he's,
we've talked and he's just like,
the things we need is for old people.
He wants to drink beer.
Oh,
when he gets older,
how old is he now?
He's six.
He's 15.
15.
Okay.
So he's gotta he's gotta wait a little while.
Yeah,
I'm going to see where Irish,
he had been drinking in utero.
Um,
but I'm not like Tommy Chong or anything.
He was like,
everybody's just moves.
We'd everybody,
I saw him at a show and he's like,
everybody in the world's just smoke weed.
And I was,
and I just leaned over and was like,
even babies,
there's a whole school out there,
which is like,
it's,
it's natural and it cures all ills and the world would be a better place if
everyone was high.
And I think no it wasn't,
you know,
we'd just be taking longer pauses in our sentences.
Nothing would work very little.
I would get done.
And that's just,
to me that's the same type of mindset where people have on anything where
they're like,
there's one thing,
if this was different,
the world would be different.
Or if like if women ruled the world,
everything would be different.
It's just like every power corrupts,
you know,
so it's not like,
Oh,
if women were on power,
you,
everyone would be nice or some things would be nicer.
And some women would be assholes and just like some guys are nice and some guys
when they get power button atheletes yeah,
I liked it.
Part of your philosophy of life is get pedicures,
get manicures.
Yes.
You have to take care of yourself?
Yeah,
I get very self conscious.
I have messed up toes.
Um,
meaning the toenails grow into the sides and it really hurts.
And I finally had to go and see someone and they,
they said,
you've got to get pedicures and I'm incredibly uncomfortable having someone,
it's,
it feels wrong.
Do you know what I mean?
It feels like,
and so I'm constantly trying to make it up to them by asking them all about
their life.
Oh,
that seems worse.
And then,
yeah,
I know they just want me to shut the fuck up.
Um,
but I want to,
you know,
I want to become their best friend because I want to compensate for the fact
that they're literally kneeling in front of me.
Oh,
caring,
caring for my feet.
You like that I like,
I'm like,
don't look me in the eyes and bring me a drink and just take care of my feet and
then I'll pay you a great amount.
It makes me feel like a king.
You would drink.
Where are you getting your toes done and they bring you a drink?
What kind of drink?
I mean you wherever you want my place.
But I mean I just drink like a sparkling water,
but if you want it like a,
a glass of whiskey or whatever.
You're kidding.
Where is this place?
Uh,
yes.
Well I have a mango now named Natasha and she's,
she's private and that's who I want to promote.
That's got the word on it.
But,
but I love this idea that they bring you a drink.
Yeah.
Natasha bring you a drink or comes to your house.
She brings me a drink.
She has her own private place.
Uh,
but I used to love this place called hammer and nails and they um,
they bring you,
it's all for men only and they would bring you a drink and can go on there.
I want to actually do an ad for them right now.
Hammer and nails.
Yeah,
I think they changed their name.
Oh,
well that didn't work.
No.
Some ad that was,
yeah,
that had was worth at least $15,000
place.
It's probably close.
Maybe they just became a bar now and they don't even do feet
drinks now.
You know what,
we're doing really well on the drinks.
Uh,
Ooh.
I figured out this,
I know we gotta wrap up,
but I'm aware,
I didn't know if,
are you aware that that most older black women call you Kona?
Are you aware of that?
Yes.
That's fine.
Yeah.
That's so fun.
Um,
I remembered I was walking down the street in New York and a very large black
woman was walking the other way towards me and she saw me and she hit her friend
on the arm and she said,
that's Conan Orion from the,
I said she got so many things wrong in such a short sentence.
You know what I mean?
That's going in Orion from the radio,
from the radio,
Orion,
Conan.
You mathematically can't be more wrong about me in a sentence.
But uh,
you know what I,
I hear a lot African Americans are always saying,
you're crazy to me.
They think I'm crazy.
They laugh and they,
they,
they're happy.
See me,
but they say you're crazy.
Yeah,
you do.
Like comedy is supposed to be,
yeah.
I think,
fool.
You're a fool.
I'm a fool.
I am crazy.
Oh,
that guy is crazy.
Yeah,
the high compliment.
Oh,
that's good.
That's good.
I then,
um,
mine's usually reversed.
One time I did this show and,
uh,
Washington and was staying with some friends and her,
his girlfriend came to the show and then we came back to his house and then he,
he is a very stereotypical,
more tougher black dude.
And then he was like,
oh,
her budget will comedy show up.
Dang.
Or her.
That's good.
He just met me for the first time,
but just talking to me,
he's like,
oh,
it's like,
you know,
you seem pretty cool.
You seem pretty funny.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm pretty fun.
He's like,
I bet black people don't fuck with you though.
[inaudible] I go,
you pretty true.
And he goes,
don't worry about it.
Black people don't fuck with most people.
It's a great insight there.
Really helped me.
That's fantastic.
Um,
yeah,
we,
uh,
we're out of time.
We've got a,
I just switched it back cause I could,
I knew that I could talk to for probably nine hours.
I probably will next week when we're flying around.
Um,
yeah.
Was Fair.
Come on.
Come to my house,
come on my podcast and a comma.
Plug it right now.
It's called game better.
What Ron Funches we just talk about getting better at life usually is about a
lot about career,
but sometimes it gets spiritual and then sometimes it's just about like,
you know,
health,
physical change.
I'll do it
if,
and will your mom be there?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm in.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to do your podcast and I'm also going to promote you as a human being.
Uh,
Ron Funches is,
uh,
one of the funniest comics working and he's also a delightful human.
Uh,
and it's just an honor to get to hang out with you.
it means a lot to me
is a literal dream come true that the fact that I'm even here.
So it means a lot to me.
And the fact that you like my comedy and you respect my comedy,
um,
when I hear the compliments like that,
and the fact that you have had me on your show so much and even when I'm haven't
had things necessarily that we're worth promoting on your show,
it makes me go,
okay,
I'm,
I'm headed in the right direction.
Yes,
yes.
And I just wanted to trick you into saying Nice things about me again to wrap it
up,
which is exactly what I just did.
All right,
Ron.
Ron Funches.
Wow.
And now it's time for another installment of Conan O'brien pays off the mortgage
on his beach house.
Either way.
There is a lot of photos out there that you take.
You take tons of photos with these digital devices.
You don't use them all?
No,
they just languish.
Why not focus on the moments that mean the most in your life by turning your
favorite digital memories into meaningful photo decor?
That's an interesting sentence.
You know what?
That's a sentence I just came up with.
I just said that.
Did you not like it?
I've never heard you say decor.
Well,
it happens to be one of my favorite words.
I don't think there's a day that goes by when I don't say meaningful photo
decor.
It's the first word my daughter ever said.
She was two years old.
She went,
meaning Paul Folk,
there's this company fracture.
They're on a mission to redefine how you print and display your favorite photos.
They print them on glass.
That's cool.
Directly on glass and you know when you give someone a photo,
like I could give you a photo of me and you might throw it away because you
don't like me.
If I give it to you on glass,
you kind of have to keep it because it's so beautiful.
Yeah.
A fracture prints there.
It's just more thoughtful to say,
here's a,
here's a picture on glass.
It's,
it makes it a more unique gift.
They're sleek.
They're,
they have a frameless design.
It goes with any decor.
It is nice cause it,
it prints,
you don't need to get a frame.
It comes in the box and you just hang it right up.
Yep.
They're handsome.
They're made in Gainesville,
Florida.
Okay.
I like any business that's in Gainesville,
Florida.
I don't care what you're doing in Gainesville,
Florida,
if you're making it in Gainesville,
I'm a customer.
I'm going just going to put that out there.
Fractures a green company.
They have a carbon neutral factory.
That's cool.
And you know what?
That's another thing.
I don't buy anything unless it's from a carbon neutral factory.
Just so specific.
Well,
that's just me.
So they sent us a fracture print.
It was really pretty.
It was.
I just wished it had been of me.
You know,
why don't you just order one of you?
I don't what?
Oh,
you're right.
I can do that.
That's the whole point of me doing this ad.
Anyway,
a beautiful quality.
Uh,
check it out for yourself.
Visit fracture me.com/conan for special discount on your first fracture order.
Don't forget to pick Conan O'Brien needs a friend in there.
One question survey,
one question survey after checkout to tell them who's sentia.
That's right.
Your old pal Conan and fracture me.com/conan.
Turn your memories into glass.
I just made that.
Just made that up.
I did a pretty good turn.
Your men don't be an ass.
Turn your memories into glass.
Okay.
This is interesting.
On a previous podcast,
sona and I had an impromptu drawing contest.
We each had to draw a dog and it was around Christmas time and then left it up
to you,
the podcast enjoyer to uh,
so what they're called podcast enjoyers podcast listeners.
It's,
it's,
it must be a better word because you can listen to a podcast,
but no,
I know,
but what's,
what's the word?
Is there a word pod?
What is listening?
Listener.
Podcast.
Because we have a whole generation that crunches everything down into one
syllable.
And you already have podcasts,
which is two syllables.
And then you add lists center,
which is three.
You'd think by now would it be called something?
People that consume podcasts,
what would you call potties?
You know,
hey,
you potties.
What's wrong with that?
Why are you laughing at that?
That is,
well,
you know,
I mean you call it a person who watches TV,
a TV viewer or a movie watcher.
So there's podcast listener.
It's the,
it's the thing.
And then what you do.
I just think it could be better.
Hey,
listen,
you potties.
We asked a bunch of you who had the better drawing,
who had the better drawing?
You voted and this is crazy.
I won a lot of you voted over 1100 people voted on this idiocy.
That's makes me sad about America.
It does.
Uh,
but you did 1100 of you voted whose puppy?
Dog with a Christmas bow drawing his best cast your vote.
The results are in 71% liked CONAN's doodle.
29% thought sona had the better doodle.
You were destroyed.
That wasn't even close tests.
No,
that is not close at all.
I had something that's supposed to be open to,
you know,
it's subjective.
Your your taste in art,
but no overwhelming.
You are a famous person.
I am not a famous person.
Nope.
That's not the reason I draw a picture of mine looking out Q minus.
That's just a,
yours has dead eyes.
That's what's funny about it.
The sea dead eyes that snoopy has,
you know that Charles Grodin has when you'd have dead eyes.
It's just funny.
And also mine has a joke.
My Dog's looking sad.
Then he's saying I'm Jewish.
He's thinking that your dog is just,
this is something you learn to draw out of a learn how to draw a puppy book.
Right?
Is it not?
In 1989 and you learned this and you've been doing it ever since mine,
this is me like Jackson Pollock or Picasso breaking through.
Effortless.
That's such a bad,
an effortless expression of creativity.
Well,
I followed the directions.
I was told the puppy with a Christmas.
Yeah,
sure.
A really cute one.
You.
Yeah.
Great artists follow directions.
Hey,
Picasso,
what's going on with those eyeballs?
They're all screwy.
See,
straighten those out and you'll learn more money on those paintings.
that would have been you if you talk that way and you lived back when Picasso
was alive,
I would tell Picasso at to do his eyeballs were all screwy.
That's not how I learned.
You've got to do as you're told and art.
No,
that's not.
That's you.
That's not me.
I am unbridled.
I cannot be tamed.
I'm a wild stallion and artistic beast.
I am smoking,
I am fire,
I am cheese and I am Cheddar.
I need to go to the hospital.
You are comparing our doodles to works by Picasso.
Well no mine,
you heard this.
This looks like uh,
there's a sick kid and his friend made this saying,
I hope you feel better.
If I were sick,
I made this puppy video and talk to me.
Tell minutes how,
wow.
I'll be make it mine.
Look the potties have spoken and uh,
I have an overwhelming 71%.
Well that means almost one out of four people preferred mine.
Yeah.
Have you seen the statistics on one out of four potties went out of four potties
or glue sniffing maniacs.
That's,
that's a fact.
One out of four.
Let's go sniff some glue.
But forest and we'll put a podcast on.
Well,
we sniff.
Oh yeah,
that's good stuff man.
I tell it now until it like,
it is
good glue that's right in there and you right to be angry.
So the people who voted for me were sniffing glue during the podcast,
then went on Twitter while they were high on glue sniffing.
I think some of the ones that voted for you didn't even know that they were on
Twitter.
I think they thought they were ordering a Domino's pizza.
No,
they thought they were ordering a pizza.
They got confused and then x and they voted accidentally for you.
If I was going to be friends with one of these puppies,
I would be friends with my puppy instead of your,
you're dead eyes puppy that has a zero fun personality to it.
It's a dumb dog.
You drew a dumb puppy when you're just assaulted.
72% of all parties.
I still think about that.
I won and I'm gracious and my victory.
Oh,
you're gracious,
Gracious.
You're a gracious winner.
Yes,
I am.
Just one thing you can say about me.
It's that I'm a gracious and humble winner.
It's not,
that's not something I would say about you and an incredible victory.
I think you're a terrible person.
That is your Goto line on me.
Say any 1%.
I know.
And you know what?
It's not true.
I think you're a nice guy.
I'm a nice guy.
In real life.
I play this crusty guy.
Um,
but really I'm one of the nicest people you've ever imagined
and we will get an editor to put something in there to make it not awkward if we
can afford that yet.
One of the nicest guys,
please.
You've met,
you haven't gotten outside a lot,
I think if you wanted to be evil,
no one could touch you.
Yes.
But you choose to use your powers for good.
So that's a nice thing.
71% crushed you.
Conan O'brien needs a frame with sona obsessing and Conan O'brien as himself
produced by me,
Matt Gorley,
executive produced by Adam Sachs and Jeff Ross at Team Coco and Collin Anderson
and Chris Bannon at Earwolf.
Special thanks to Jack White and the white stripes for the theme song.
Incidental music by Jimmy Vivino.
You can rate and review this show on apple podcasts and you might find your
review featured on a future episode.
Got a question for Conan,
call the team coco hotline at (323) 451-2821 and leave a message it to could be
featured on a future episode.
And if you haven't already,
please subscribe to Conan O'brien needs a friend on apple podcasts,
stitcher or wherever.
Fine podcasts are down.
Okay.
This has been cocoa production in association with
happy
New Year Earwolf fans.
Guys.
2018 is ober not a moment too soon.
Challenging year.
However,
a real bright spot was doing whole mafia.
That's right.
I uh,
I love it.
I'm Dave Holmes.
I'm Matt McConkey and we had such a good time this year doing this show.
Uh,
if you are not familiar,
hemophilia is a podcast here at Earwolf where Matt and I talked to awesome LGBT
queer plus people,
celebrities date,
let's just say celebrities,
geniuses,
creators,
makers,
movers,
shakers,
um,
uh,
about the pop culture that they're loving and the people that they're living.
We had a ton of great guests,
2018 including Jesse Tyler Ferguson.
Maybe you've heard of him for a little show called modern family.
He's telling us the story about the time he got caught shoplifting gay porn.
Oh,
all the blood rushed to my stomach.
I just felt such compassion for him.
Uh,
Matt Rogers of last Culture East is talking about losing his virginity to the
manager of a clam bar.
No.
So romantic.
It's not always glamorous fence.
The great Rhea butcher,
uh,
giving us essentially a masterclass on gender fluidity.
Robert Brown.
Oh yes.
Talking about marriage and then like moments after the show drops,
proposing to his boyfriend and also during the episode flirting heavily with
Dave Holmes.
Is that related to the proposal that I followed shortly after?
I don't know.
You have to listen to find out.
Not For us to know.
Uh,
Dan savage,
who,
you know,
he's,
he's a genius.
Sex and Love Guru right here near Wolf,
breaking down,
being monogamous.
Tom's more,
uh,
it was a great year.
Uh,
if you like really good stories,
if you like laughing a ton,
if you like going real deep on your pop culture,
uh,
and your,
your,
your self help,
your queer theory,
but fun.
Listen to hemophilia with me,
Dave Holmes and me and Matt McConkie.
It's on apple podcasts or stitcher or wherever you get your,
you.